If you were turned into a magical girl
out of nowhere, what would you do?
This popular game is turning
everyone's dreams into reality,
but it's hiding a deadly secret.
I'm going to break down the mistakes made,
what you should do, and how to beat the death
game in a magical girl raising project.
This innocent girl is about to be trapped
in a fight for her life.
Koyuki.
Here is your everyday teenager
and she loves the magical girls
taking the bus with her friends.
They ask Koyuki if she believes the recent
magical girl sightings are real.
They flick through the new
seeing stories of magical girls helping
civilians out in all kinds of situations.
The friends realize
that Koyuki really likes magical girls,
so they introduce her to a new game
called magical girl raising project.
Koyuki admits, though, that she's already
on the game and she loves to play it.
However, this cute little game is about
to turn into something much more sinister.
That night she plays the game and decides
to stop when her mom calls her for dinner.
She tries to quit, but she finds out that
there's a secret event happening right now.
The game's mascot, Fav, tells her
that he's been following her progress
throughout the game and has decided
to appoint her as a real life magical girl.
A button is then shown on the screen
and Koyuki decides to press it.
Suddenly she begins her transformation into
the same magical girl she plays in the game.
Snow White, realizing
that her lifelong dreams have just come true.
She jumps in joy and hits the roof.
Fav informs her that her physical abilities
have been increased to extreme levels.
He gives her a magical phone
and tells her
that there are 15 other magical girls
in the city, each with unique abilities.
Her ability is to hear
the thoughts of those in trouble.
Their goal is to collect
as many magical candies as possible, showing
how many people they've help.
He also tells her that
no matter what she does,
no civilians will be able to interact
or see her.
Okay, we've just been given a gift from
the gods, and the possibilities are endless.
We can do whatever we want to go
wherever we like,
and no one can tell us otherwise,
at least for now.
The first thing I would do
is to try to steal a whole lot of money
because I want to live a nice and easy life,
you know what I mean?
I would not be surprised
if some of them haven't already done this.
We're magical girls.
We don't really have to play by the law,
do we?
I would be pretty darn excited, but also
pretty darn careful with what's going on.
Remember, kids,
if you're signing a contract,
it's always important to read the fine print.
Devil's in the details.
We've completely signed our life away
to a low quality mobile game,
and we have no idea what the reputation
of this game company is like.
In fact, it might do us some good to Google
the company before making such a life
changing agreement, don't you think?
Regardless, though,
of the contractual obligations,
we've already signed off and now we're locked
into the magical girl life for good.
And I might not end up
being as sweet as it is right now.
Not only are we going out
way past our bedtime,
we still got to attend school
and do all of that normal day to day crap.
And we also need to consider
what kind of effects
this is going to have on our mental health.
Staying up every single night.
It might be cool
being a magical girl right now,
but what happens when we grow up to have kids
and other adult obligations?
It might be a little bit of a pain in the ass
to go stop crime at three in the morning
when you got to wake up at six,
feed the kids, take out the garbage,
and then go to work.
A week later,
Fav tells her that she should meet up
with the other magical girls
and gives her the ability
to enter a chat room with others like her.
She enters the room and is greeted
by the other magical girls
who congratulate Koyuki
on getting the highest amount
of magical candies for this week.
Koyuki is flattered,
but she's about to find out
that these new friends
are going to want her dead very soon.
She leaves the chat room
and is given a message to meet
one of the magical girls at the nearby tower.
She travels to the destination and flies
to the top of the tower to see another girl,
and this mysterious girl introduces herself
as La Pucelle
and offers to introduce her to the duties
of being a magical girl.
She tells Koyuki that each magical girl
has a different district of the city
that they must protect.
And that's when this pair of magical girls
pass by to meet Koyuki.
They introduce themselves as the outgoing
top speed and the quiet but cool ripple.
Suddenly, La Pucelle reveals
that she's actually a guy but moving on
and that he's known Koyuki for a while
since they both went
to the same elementary school
and both loved the same game.
A few days pass by and five announces
that he'll be cutting in
half the amount of magical girls
as the man of the city can't handle
having 15 magical girls all at once.
And he tells the girls that week by week,
the magical girls
with the least amount of candies will be cut
until only eight remain.
The week after,
the girls wait in the chat room
to see who got the highest amount
of magical candies for the week.
The winners announced as Koyuki,
and the loser is announced
as this light hearted girl.
And she admits that she might have been
spending too much time in the chat room
and says goodbye to the rest of the girls.
Suddenly, a message says that
that girl has been deleted.
The real life version of her
sighs as she realizes that the fun is over
five tells her
that she still has until midnight to use her
magical girl abilities,
and that's when she decides
to dip into the fantasy world
for one last time, looking over a little girl
watching a princess roll
by back in the real world,
her mother walks in to see how she's doing
and she tries waking her daughter up.
But she's shocked to find out
that her daughter is dead.
The night after, Koyuki and La Pucelle
sit around wondering how that girl is doing
and they get a call from this holy girl,
Sister Nana and this ninja girl Winter Prison
who informs her that that girl has died,
and every girl
who loses their magical abilities
will follow the same fate.
Okay. Holy shit.
What everyone thought was an innocent game
meant to help the citizens of this city
has made a turn for the worse.
Now, everyone here could be an enemy,
and we'll have to go from saving citizens
to get candies to saving ourselves
now, I know power in
numbers is an important thing. Yes.
And we have our trustworthy buddy La Pucelle,
who seems really determined to protect us
no matter what.
And his sword looks like he can take out
our enemies pretty dang easily.
However,
we need to consider the rules of this game
and how we can abuse them to our advantage.
It's pretty damn obvious that this magical
candy thing is all a ploy to get us to fight.
Being able to transfer
between other magical girls
makes no sense, and helping our civilians
is not the most efficient way to stay alive.
If I were Koyuki,
since we know that there are 14 other girls
still alive and with the other mystery girl
that hasn't come out of hiding yet,
the most efficient way to satisfy
the demands that Fav has given us
is to join up with seven other girls with
a group of eight will take out the other six
and destroy the mystery girl
whenever she shows up.
And of course, this is easier said than done.
I know, considering that
some girls already have paired up
and might have relations that go
beyond the game like me and La Pucelle,
now there is another option
that it might be a bit risky.
We know that every single magical girl
in this game
also exists in the real world, and that means
that if they die in the real world, well,
what happens, folks?
They die in the game too.
We all know that these girls live
within the same city,
or at least pretty damn close to it.
If we find a way to track these girls
in the real world
and it's not that hard through social media,
we could follow them around during the day
and try to take them out in the real world.
While
this might seem like a great idea on paper,
this will also probably lead us
to getting arrested for murder.
So this option is definitely more
of a last ditch idea.
All of the girls enter the chat room to hear
the announcement Fav is going to make.
The doll tells them the truth if they come up
short with their magical candies
or drop out of the game,
they'll die in real life.
Koyuki in LA
Pucelle said at the top of the tower
wondering who the next seven to die
are going to be she begins crying and La
Pucelle promises to protect her
no matter what.
That's when they get a notice informing them
that they can transfer
magical candies among one another.
Meanwhile, another group of magical girls
set to listening to their leader,
and she tells them that
this notice isn't meant to make sure
everyone has equal candies.
Rather, it means that they need to kill
and steal from whoever has the most candies.
Koyuki and la Pucelle read that
a 16th girl will soon be revealed
and they're excited to see who she is
when suddenly
these two twins attack them on sight and La
Pucelle chases them down to a nearby shipyard
and the twins demand that she hand over her
candies.
Pissed off, La Pucelle attacks the twins and
tells them to run off before she kills them.
However, the twins
have a plan up their sleeves
and they activate a trap, opening the ground
below La Pucelle and trapping her inside.
Meanwhile, the leader and swimsuit team
ambush Koyuki
and tell her their true intentions
they're going to kill her and they lured her
best friend far away to make it easy.
Suddenly the leader cast a spell on her
which freezes her completely and tells Swim
swim to drain the girl of all of her candies.
Back at the shipyard,
La Pucelle reveals that she was never trapped
and jumps
out of the pit to attack the twins
and she noticed them
transform into an eagle
and begins to fly away. That's
when she realizes that the entire thing
was a ploy to distract her from the tower.
La Pucelle follows
the twins and watches as swim swim drains
Koyuki of her candies angered she increases
the size of her sword and bangs the tower,
causing everyone on top of it to fall off.
And La Pucelle catches Kabuki and tells her
that they need to get the candies back.
The rankings will be released today
and she'll be put in last place.
Okay.
Love Puzzle is a massive bro
and we should be doing whatever we can
to save our own butts.
She's offering to help us out,
and we should be taking
whatever help that we can get.
If I was Koyuki,
I need to be very aware of the fact
that I basically have zero combat abilities
and am totally useless.
Not only that, we're facing absolute killers
that can easily hunt us down and murderous
in brutal fashion.
Our first order of business
is to get our candies back.
If we don't, we'll die.
At this point, it might be our best bet
to have the amount of candies
that we have with Lop who sell.
That way, we don't have to deal with that.
Group of evil girls just yet,
and we might have just enough
to beat out of some other schmuck
who's not been gathering as much candies
as everyone else.
Once this whole candy business is over,
and done with, our next priority
should be to learn some fighting moves
from our dear old friend here.
He seems to know a lot about combat
and his skills with weapons,
which seems to be pretty darn use.
Judging by what just happened between us
and the evil, magical girls.
Also,
since we can't be seen by regular citizens,
it might be worth trying to head over
to one of the many gun stores
available in Japan and borrow
whatever heavy artillery guns we can find.
We don't know how effective guns
can be against magical girls yet,
but it's a hell of a lot better
than being completely defenseless
and I say steal some guns because good luck
trying to get one legally from those bad boys
in the Sunrise Kingdom
without any hassle back at the hideout.
Swim, swim checks to see that
she's gained around 2000 candies from Koyuki.
The leader tells them that
she's not going to split the candies equally.
Rather she'll give 1000 to herself.
500 to swim swim and the remaining 500
to the other three girls.
She calls
the others idiots for nearly ruining the plan
and checks the weekly rankings to see
that she has been
ranked the lowest out of the girl
as she lays in a pool of her own blood.
The twins
celebrate realizing that their plan worked.
Swim, swim transferred the stolen candies
to this dog loving girl Tama equaling
25,000 stolen candies and swim swim reveals
that Koyuki has 50,000 but decided to play
nice and only still have swim some hides
the body of the real life leader
while appointing herself
as the new leader of the group.
Meanwhile Ripple and top speed
meet with Sister Nona,
who suggests that they put an end
to this senseless violence.
The magical girl called Calamity
Mary enjoys a drink with this robot
here, commenting that she's earning Candice
by doing both good and bad deeds.
The robot tells her that she needs to go
see Sister
Nona and help her out with a certain problem.
She meets with both Sister
Nona and Winter Prison, telling them
that she has some special connections
with the admins of the server.
But it's going to cost money.
The sister hands it over, but winter
prison isn't too sure that the robot
is completely truthful.
They receive a text from Wild Cranberry
asking to meet at a nearby quarry and head.
They're instantly there.
They meet up and sister
Nona tells the girl that they need
to put a stop to the other magical girls
stealing candies and harming each other.
Wild Cranberry tells her that she has
some other things in mind and tells Sister
Nona to stop preaching and ruining the game.
Hearing this winter prison stands in front of
the sister and wild cranberry attacks them.
They fight it out in winter prison quickly
realizes that she's no match for the evil,
magical girl.
She wrecks stone walls around her
to position her
to trap her and grab Sister
Nona running away.
Wild cranberry easily gets out of the trap
and watches
as the two barely make it out alive.
Five pops up and questions
why she didn't kill them.
But she admits
that winter prison is a worthy opponent
and that they'll meet again sometime soon.
Later that night, the injured girls meet up
with the 16th contestant Hardgore Alice.
Sister Nona tells her that it's up to them
to stop the fighting and mentions
that Koyuki was attacked
for having the most candy.
She reveals her location and Hardgore Alice
instantly leaves to go find her.
Okay.
If I were sister nana,
i would probably take the time
to reassess my situation
and maybe call it a day.
Call it quits
while she is doing something very admirable
and very noble in the death game
that is full of liars, cheaters,
and tricksters.
You're either going to be a scumbag and leave
or you're going to die now as nana.
Our special ability is to draw
the full potential of our loved ones power.
And that special person is winter prison
out of all the magical girls in the game,
were the only two people
that are pretty much a combo deal.
Just like burger and fries.
Delicious winter prison special ability
is to make waffles out of nowhere.
And combined with the nanas abilities,
we should be able to make enough walls
to trap the entire city.
However, we don't need to forget
about all of our heroic ideals
it's just a matter of finding those
who share the same ideas
as us and combining our forces to take
the magical girls who are pure evil out.
And who else could be the perfect fit
for the job other than our very own.
Koyuki and la Pucelle.
Meanwhile, Koyuki and la Pucelle
say their goodbyes for the night.
That's when la Pucelle looks behind her
to see wild cranberry waiting for her.
This time, one on one,
they moved to the dockyards to make sure
no civilians get injured and battle it out.
La Pucelle tries to get at her,
but a wild cranberry is too much.
The evil, magical girl and niece
are off of the building and vows to kill her.
She leaves her in a pool of her own blood
and is about to land the final blow
when la Pucelle just barely dodges
grabbing her sword
and she runs at the evil girl
knowing that she won't survive.
In the chatroom,
five notices that only two magical girls
have shown up to hear the results and
she tells the girls that the game has added
five new items, all with unique abilities.
However, there's only one of each.
Secondly,
she announces that La Pucelle is dead
due to an accident
since someone has already died.
The lowest ranked magical girl
is saved from elimination this week.
Later, five tries
advertising one of the items to Koyuki
who declines and says
that she's not going to fight anymore.
Five mentions
that her friend may have been killed
by another magical girl and that these items
may help her fight off any incoming enemies.
Five Also tells her
that these items don't cost any money.
However, they do take off years of your life.
The more powerful
they are, the more years they take off.
Coyote clicks on the sword.
But realize that it's along with every other
item has been already bought.
Suddenly Hardgore Alice finds her
sitting all by herself and she walks
towards the helpless girl when the robot
comes out of nowhere and brutally kills her.
The robot admits that she's here to
kill her as well, but the robot ends up
being brutally murdered, just like Alice.
Okay, we've just missed a golden opportunity.
Looking at each individual item, I would say
it would be time for us to take the risk
and do whatever it takes to beat this game
instead of waiting around like Koyuki did.
Five has tricked us many times before.
We know, but there's no way for that
little snot to prove that all of these items
can take years off of our life,
especially if we win the game.
We have to question
everything that this little turd says,
no matter how ridiculous it may seem.
If it were me, I would have taken
every single gosh darn weapon on this list.
Our only goal is to beat this death game
and make it out alive.
So even if they have to sacrifice
a few decades off of my life, I'm young.
I have plenty more decades left to spare.
I shouldn't have to worry about it
after I make it out of the death game alive.
Thinking about it more carefully, though,
how can Fav predict how many years of life
we have left in the first place
at this point, it might have the answer
to the meaning of life itself
by using some of these weapons.
For example, the invisibility cloak,
which takes 25 years off of our life,
we can essentially cheat the game
and hide away forever
until the other magical girls
take themselves out.
Not only that, as far as we know,
we should be able to use the cloak with
other people, meaning we can protect and hide
whoever else wants to join the cloak gang.
If we put all the numbers together,
that would equate to 49 years of life.
Considering that we're still in school
and Japanese
people live to be pretty dang old,
there's a very good chance
that we'll be decades from dying.
Even after purchasing the items,
Koyuki wakes up with a keychain on her hand
and she's confused, and Fav suggests that
she might have picked it up the night before.
Five mentions that Hardgore Alice
was the last person to have it, and Koyuki
realizes that everything that she experienced
wasn't a simple nightmare.
It was real
and that's when she gets a text from Sister
Nona asking to meet at a secluded location.
Meanwhile, on the chat, room
five announces
that the robot has died, meaning that
there won't be a loser
eliminated from this week's rankings.
Koyuki meets up with Sister Nona and not
a consults are about La Pucelle's death.
They agree to work together
so they can stop the mindless deaths,
but that's when Koyuki notices Hardgore Alice
standing in the distance, shocked.
Alice
agrees to work with them as well, and Sister
Nona tells them that she'll be going off
to meet with more magical girls.
Koyuki runs out of the warehouse
but is creepily followed by alice.
She offers her the key chain
saying that it belongs to Koyuki
and she explains
that she can regrow parts of her body,
meaning that she wasn't killed
the other night.
Her head was chopped off,
but she regrouped and is back to normal.
Dang, we need to watch out for this girl.
If being able to make walls here
people's thoughts
and make your own sword increase inside
exponentially wasn't crazy enough.
Hardgore Alice here has just changed the game
big time.
This little girl has the lottery
with her ability.
She can't be killed.
Which means the only way we can lose the game
is by having the least amount of points.
Judging by how depressed she looks.
She might not realize how lucky she is,
especially compared to
Koyuki is crappy ability.
If anything, the rest of the contestants
should look to make a truce
with this girl asap by stopping the killings
for at least one week
to go collect some candies.
But we know that's never going to happen.
Sister Nona confronts Calamity Mary, saying
that she's been using magic to commit crimes,
which is against the magical girl
code of conduct.
Mary tells her to not stand in her way
and fires a gun at nana winter prison, erects
a massive wall to protect them and runs away
from Mary with nana in her arms.
They travel to swim swims
hideout where Sister
Nona thanks her
for sending the stolen candies
she took from the leader
without a response swims when pieces forward
and sends a robotic version of Sister Nana
to attack the innocent girls.
Suddenly,
Winter Prison is stabbed by Robot Nana
and they reveal themselves
to be the twins in disguise.
However, winter prison isn't as hurt
as the evil, magical girls thought,
and she erects a few massive walls
to trap the girls in.
That's when Winter Prison kills
one of the twins and jumps out of the trap
to take out the other. But it's too late.
She's slashed by swim swim,
which kills her on the spot.
Meanwhile, Ripple and top speed wait around
on a rooftop to meet up with Calamity Mary.
Suddenly they're shot at
and realize that Mary is out to kill them.
They hop on to Ripple's broomstick
and ride off, avoiding her gunshots.
The human version of Koyuki watches from
outside of her window as they fight it out.
Civilians are dying left and right
and mary is causing havoc in the city.
Koyuki turns back into a magical girl and
is joined by Alice, who promises to help her.
Hell yeah.
If Alice isn't lying to us for some reason,
that would suck
Then we've essentially beaten the game.
If I were Koyuki
i'd be the happiest, magical girl
alive right now and i'd also avoid
getting involved in this massive war
going on outside of my house.
Using my abilities,
i should be able to read calamity
mary's mind to find out that she's truly
absolutely nuts and that she's out to kill
whoever stands in her way,
whether that be civilians or magical girls.
Her finesse with weapons
is enough to take out anyone from miles away,
and that means she's a dangerous individual,
which we have no chance fighting against
since
however, alice seems to be indebted to us,
I'd simply
let her go and take care of business.
She'll be able to take
whatever punishment comes her way,
and that means she's a valuable asset to us.
Now that our trusty
lad Pucelle is dead in the water,
Mary continues shooting bullets at Ripple
and top speed, trying to kill them both.
Ripple decides to take matters into her own
hands.
And jumps off of the broomstick
to face her mano-a-mano and they fight it out
and accidentally
Ripple steps onto a landmine.
Suddenly, Mary whips out grenades
and nearly kills the girl Luckily, top speed
catches are on the broomstick
and saved her life.
They travel back to the roof
and send the broomstick flying
through the building, trying it
one more time.
They get caught by Mary sniper rifle
sending them flying into a nearby warehouse.
Now they realize that they need to face her
head on and kill her now,
or else they'll be hunted
for the rest of the game.
They launch a surprise attack,
throwing a shuriken
into the girl's head and killing Calamity
Mary for good.
They give each other a hug,
but Rebel sees blood on her hands.
Shocked, she looks over top speed
shoulder to see. Swim, swim.
Who just brutally murdered her best friend.
The girl becomes enraged and attacked.
Swim, swim with all of her power.
However, the pink haired girl is too strong
and disappears into the building.
She looks over at top speed to see her
human form appear, meaning she's dead.
And she realizes that in her human
form, Top Speed was pregnant
and wanted to survive the game.
Six more months to give birth.
Meanwhile, the Twins arrive to help out
the mess left by Calamity Mary.
Suddenly she throws an ax into Alice's face
and Koyuki realizes
that she's not here to help
and that's when she hears
the thoughts of another girl and listens.
And to hear another girl about to attack.
The Twin Schools are for being caught
and Tommy disappears into the ground.
Back in the real world, the news reports
on the massive amount of destruction
caused by the magical girls.
But they have no idea where it came from.
Sister Nana decides to call it quits.
Becoming another victim of the death game.
Five announces that a grand total
of five magical girls have died, meaning that
seven girls remain
and the game should be over.
However, he has another announcement to make
and he needs to cut in half
the amount of magical girls again,
this time to four.
That night,
Koyuki and Alice meet up at the beach,
and she thanks the girl for helping her out.
And they hear the news from faith
that only four girls will be allowed
to survive.
Hearing this Koyuki freaks out and demands
that they stop the killing running away
out of anger. Okay, at this point.
Koyuki And the magical girl
should realize that this game is pure evil.
Not only have all the girls been brutally
killing each other,
causing utter destruction to the city
and a lifetime of therapy,
but pulling a bait and switch
and asking us to keep on playing games
means that we can't trust this game at all.
If i was Koyuki
i would try to make the other girls
call it quits on the whole killing business.
We know that Fav
and whoever else is behind it.
The raising project isn't telling the truth
and this game is going to likely
get us all killed in the end.
Now what can we do to get out of this mess?
There are four of us left, and both Alice
and rebel are on our side.
Swim sim looks like she's hopeless,
so we should kill her to make sure
that she doesn't try to mess with us anymore,
even though she's an absolute beast.
It's three against one
and there's a very good chance
that we can beat her
out of the remaining three magical girls.
She seems to be the type to make a pact
and then backstab us,
and it's in our best interest
to take out any possible loose strength
so that we can focus on the task at hand.
We need to escape this game
no matter what it takes.
What we should do
is to look into the previous deaths
of the other magical girls,
specifically those who died
without any external circumstances
being involved like that girl, and see what
caused them to die.
If we go full on private investigator mode,
we should also be able
to find some news on what caused certain
magical girls like herself to bite the dust.
From there,
we might be able to decipher a way
to quit the game
and go back to our normal lives,
forgetting everything that happened here.
Hell, at some point
it might be in our best interest
to take a visit to the local police station
and tell them what's going on.
While they might think us crazy,
there shouldn't be anything
stopping us from transforming
right in front of them
and proving what we're saying is true.
After that,
we could spread the news to the entire world
and get everyone involved in figuring out
a way to release us from this disturbing game
responsible for killing innocent people.
The next day,
Alice is attacked while in human form, and
she runs to a nearby alleyway to transform
but is finished off by swim swim.
In her final breath, she remembers that
she needs to give back the key chain.
Suddenly, Koyuki realizes something is off
when she gets home from school
and she turns into a magical girl
and jumps across the city
to see the crowd of bystanders
standing around an empty coat.
She overhears what they're saying
and finds herself in the alleyway
where Alice is lying in her human form.
She thanks Koyuki for all that she's done
and gives her the key chain before she dies
that night, swims when and her gang
hatch a plan to ambush Wild Cranberry Swim.
Swim enters her house to find it
completely empty.
While Cranberry here is walking outside,
she knows exactly what's going on and grabs
a rock, throwing it onto the ground
to reveal the twins now dead.
Tama apologizes to swim, swim for messing up
and they walk over to see the twins lifeless
body swim
swim tries to surprise attack cranberry
but she dodges and causes a massive explosion
destroying all of the surrounding trees.
She goes to finish her off but is surprised
to see that her human form is a child.
Tomoe comes from behind,
hitting her with a magic item.
Suddenly, Cranbury
blows up and slumps to the ground.
Tom runs over to swim, swims human form,
and she gets back up, showing little to
no injuries.
She transforms back into a magical girl
and chops
Thomas head off killing the innocent girl.
She mutters to herself that she can't let
her real identity be known.
That night, Fav announces the weekly rankings
this time, four girls have been killed,
so the number of magical candies
don't matter anymore.
And the game is essentially over.
With three girls remaining in her human form,
Koyuki receives the text from Ripple,
and they meet up at a nearby tower and Ripple
asks her for any information about swim.
Swim.
Koyuki is confused since the game is over,
but Ripple vows to take revenge
for the death of her friend.
Five pops up and wants the girl
to be scared of swim swim.
Everyone who's tried to mess with her
has died,
but he mentions that the mass murderer
has one weakness light and sound.
Five mentions
that the amount of magical girls
might have been reduced to two and urges
Ripple to get her revenge back at her place.
Koyuki tells Fav that she wants to quit
being a magical girl.
Five is shocked
and says that she's a valuable candidate
for having survived so long.
Five reveals that the entire thing
is a recruitment project,
picking one of the magical girls
to become a member of the world of magic.
This allows them to become a full time,
a magical girl or become a master
like Fav and conduct a further magical girl.
Raising Project Star reveals
that Wild Cranberry was a master
but was killed by Swim Swim.
Now that the other two girls are fighting,
all Koyuki has to do is wait
until they kill each other to win the game.
Okay.
Now, while I know
it might seem like a really bad idea
to listen to the very person
that got us into this mess,
agreeing with five right now
might be a good idea.
While the magical girl
raising project may be very quick,
twisted, demented and responsible
for killing some of our very good friends,
it is going to lead us to our dream
of becoming a full time, magical girl.
Now we can do whatever we want
for the rest of our lives,
whether that be to travel
to different countries, eat
nice food we've always dreamt about, and
never spend another day in school ever again.
Because school sucks
or we can become the master
and make sure that this deadly
cycle of death games never happens again.
It's something to consider since we've gone
through a ridiculous amount of trials
and tribulations to get to this point.
There's no turning back.
Even if we decide to team up
with the other magical girls
and try to put an end to these games.
If we become a master,
we can make sure that the future games
and participants
aren't as deadly as the ones before.
All we have to do
is scope out the magical girls
that aren't crazy children like swim, swim,
and perhaps by using a better selection
process than a simple video game,
hearing this Koyuki turns into a magical girl
and breaks her phone,
stopping all communication with five,
she rushes over to stop them from fighting.
But she's too late.
And she arrives to see the human form
of swim, swim impaled on the ground
and looks over to find that
ripple is also dead.
Five pops up again, congratulating her
for surviving without fighting once
and she attempts to break
the device that five is pumping out of,
but five tells her that it's impossible.
Suddenly, she looks up to find that
Ripple is still alive.
She goes over to Fav and breaks
the air with her sight.
Six months later, Koyuki's friends discuss
how popular the town has become since all
the strange events began popping up.
And they talk about the Magical Girl
Racing Project being deleted.
But notice that there are still supposed
sightings on the news.
Seeing this reminds them of Koyuki
and they wonder
what happened to their good friend
after all this time.
And if you want to get out of this
death game filled with magical girls, don't
forget to like comment.
Subscribe and check out the
horrible playlist down below.